hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica so it's
the middle of the night and we got a new
seamoth and we're not going anywhere
near that ship ever again because even
when we did go near there it didn't give
us what we needed so what we need to do
and I looked it up it does confirm you
do find the moonpool blueprints from the
fragments it says which are the little
things Oh day came so quick I love that
so what I'm gonna do in an area that I
have not explored very much is an area
like behind my original starting point
over there and staying like parallel to
the ship so I'm gonna continue in this
direction hopefully find very nice
monsters such as Sean thun thun thun
thun snow and then everything's gonna be
much better ooh
I never went fully through one of these
caves before yay for coral yay I am at
84% health already did I hit myself what
the hell happened in that tube how is
this possible I just built this thing I
need to build that repair module because
this is not okay like I can't stop I
can't keep building these things over
and over again it's just plain douchey
god damnit thousand I blasted them into
blood you're coming to me I'm gonna eat
you
just because you inconvenience me
terraformer I already have the
terraformer it's gonna give me titanium
I know that but I'm doing this out of
spite because I need what I need I also
have not checked out the area far to the
that way of my roof art yes far to the
that way of my original base most of my
exploration has been in just very narrow
directions and I need to go out so I
will be back you will see a montage of
me getting scared random things that
I've already seen in the ocean what
nothing else is new so I'll be back what
is that what is what is what is this
you're new and probably not friendly you
just vanished okay so I'm in a new area
a new biome I think and while that is
very cool and I don't like that I like
that they're all technically not okay
I'm not seeing any fragments anywhere
but I haven't looked very thoroughly
I've been a little distracted at the
horrifying this about a tall tiger Jesus
didn't hurt that didn't hurt at all did
you just chip your tooth ha ha ha loser
I'm gonna go see what this is
Cyclops pressure compensator okay that
that's what I need but that is that's
the depth that's the depth thing for my
big sub but I need it for the small sub
ah I'm in the right area
very nice hope I don't get bitten that
would be bad but I'm dunno get away from
me I see you over there don't even think
about it bro I don't even know what you
is I'm gonna scan you tree mushroom I
don't want to scan the tree mushroom
maybe I do want to scan the tree
mushroom never mind okay got that now
what the Frick are you seriously what
are you with your weird tentacles I
didn't know they were still new fur
didn't mean to do Explorer what are you
jelly ray oh I should have known very
very obvious okay Jesus I do not like
the noises in this area there's some
definite death definite hints of death
everywhere around er
that so cool though oh look at it all
moves so after I find this I got all
these that I need so then maybe the
other things are in a different biome or
there's more thing things in this biome
apologies I got another bleep room noob
Libre acquired what is that the lithium
there is lithium okay I thought that was
only available in the deep deep so
that's good because now I got it in here
I need to head back eventually because
I'm gonna run out of water and food I'm
gonna run out a lot of things including
sanity if I'm not careful whoa hello
high wall how are you doing
okay I guess I'm leaving this biome now
was there like a cave or something or
new okey okay back into the area that
I'm familiar with and I'm okay with in
the slow monsters unless I'm just gonna
stumble across another area with another
area with death exactly what I didn't
want to do and then I did the thing I
said I was not gonna do it and then I
did it what was I thinking
I'm so stupid stupid getting lose
another favor can't put Geoffrey Billy
Samwise Marshall through that whoa hey
what are you doing hey stop it I want to
know what's down there maybe I can get
in through the back way hey someone's
rumbling and I don't like rumbles oh
yeah I'm going in manual here we go
what was that hey hey well it's a girl
bro you want to go huh let's go who's
going am I going to someone is something
going never mind okay
wired dammit stop it who's doing that
we're doing the thing
oh it's shooting at me oh I was going
with nobody I'm not gonna go in there
that's dangerous okay god there's so
many things oh there's so many things
that I have yet to explore in this game
it's fascinating there's still new stuff
there's something down there hang on
there's a cave hello I'm sorry okay is
it just me or do the coral on the wall
look like faces that are very sad and or
angry straight out of a horror movie
shouldn't touch that with a name like
dropping stinger it's probably not gonna
be very healthy for me
shuttle bug okay that's kind of a cute
name I can deal with that probably not
gonna kill me I thought I got trapped in
here stop hitting my goddamn hole with
your fish bodies again stop it it's just
rude at this point I'm trying to go
about my day to day life and you're
ruining my nice new ship down to 61%
already this bull I don't want to go
down there no thank you but there's got
to be more Oh
ground me more it's gotta be hello
Sancho
there's gotta be more no matter what
before this episode is over I'm gonna
get this what oh why did I circle all
the way back around I was going the
completely opposite direction that
doesn't that doesn't make any sense what
this doesn't make any sense
I got a lot of blood stains on my ship
just because so many fish have just
splattered up against the side I'm just
gonna go to my ship my original dropship
go past it save everything else and then
just go about my business and no one is
gonna bother me cuz I'm just gonna keep
going in one direction forever and ever
until eventually one of my members leave
and then the whole band breaks up or
throws on a break and then reconvenes
nine years later when one of them
actually has a career and everyone else
is a failed dropout well as I talking
about
I don't know subnautica or something
whoa
whoa where are we now what the hell is
that what is that what are those are
those giant floaties and these are giant
floating rocks
there's so many new things I thought I
explored everything what the Hankey hell
what the hockey hell my goodness
gracious
they got courts out the ass apparently
weird choral stuff lots of fish stop it
you're getting nowhere you need to give
up on your dreams stop
am I just is this is nothingness is this
life now Oh which way is up where am I
what the hell I hope I'm going towards
the moon my god I was in the thick of it
this is crazy oh it's so deep oh it's so
deep I don't like it oh it's so deep oh
that was so deep I was like the deepest
I've ever been oh my god
oh so deep oh where am I
oh it's so far away I don't like it I
should have taken my big sub my big boy
sub I can't even see the wreckage from
here good lordy um well no going back
now I'm gonna press on I guess even
though it's just total abyss you know
like I don't like this
I want daytime now there's nothing it's
nothing it's just a whole lot of nothing
yep lights on oh my god oh god I don't
even know if the sun's rays are gonna
penetrate deep enough to see what's at
the bottom of this bowl I'm pretty sure
I just reached an area where there is no
more game world and it's just empty
ocean that's what I want to believe
I still don't see anything and it is
actually daytime this is terrible this
is terrifying it's gonna take me forever
to get back god I was going a long time
out that way
holy crap this is this this is my
nightmare this is my nightmare of being
lost in the ocean in the middle of the
ocean because the ocean is deeper than
this like it's deeper than that oh god I
can barely see something eventually I'm
gonna get the upgrades necessary to get
down there but oh god oh it's not okay
just floating out in the middle of the
ocean knowing that there's monsters more
terrifying than water in this game oh
god what is that I thought that was like
I thought that was like a statue or
something so weird all right well
there's a thing there
you better have what I need oh please
dear goodness please I cannot find this
moonpool thing to save my life the only
other place that I haven't really
explored I think is actually near the
ship who stasis rifle did I get this ISA
I don't think I got this stasis rifle
link okay so I actually had one so that
means that I haven't actually checked
all the things in the creepvine area so
that must mean there's a possibility
that there is something else here
ah damn it I need to make another Power
Cell for this thing oh I've been running
all over the entire ocean and I've yet
to find what I need
that is aggravating but obviously I
think the problem is I'm not just not
looking in the right area there's got to
be a very specific biome with which this
appears because they noticed some
consistencies and where the fragments
spawn based on the biome so if there's
got to be something else to that I'm
just not seeing it oh yeah okay so I got
that and I'm doing okay but I was
running way too long I really wanted to
find the moonpool but I need you guys
help with it I'm gonna be finding give
me advice where to go then I'm gonna get
it and then I'm going to do something
about the big monster which is still
haunting my dreams so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always see you